ja das wird spannend aber ich glaube gar
nicht so amüsant aber ich habe
eigentlich ein sehr ernstes thema
mitgebracht und zwar will die ampel
zuwanderung attraktiver machen ich finde
das sehr gut ich finde im
koalitionsvertrag wies aufgeführt ist
für mich sogar grandios denn wir haben
ein totales problem was den
fachkräftemangel betrifft die zahl
beträgt insgesamt werden derzeit etwa
1,2 millionen arbeitskräfte davon zwei
drittel fachkräfte gesucht das sagt der
chef der bundesagentur für arbeit die
ampel bereits entgegen wirken und die
zuwanderung attraktiver machen ist sie
schreiben eine einbürgerung soll in der
regel nach fünf jahren möglich sein bei
besonderen integrationsleistung nach
drei jahren und das finde ich besonders
wichtig arbeitsverbot für bereits in
deutschland leben schaffen wir ab das
ist ein unfassbar wichtiger punkt für
mich weil ich habe nicht erst als im
flüchtlingsheim gearbeitet habe 2017
gedacht warum dürfen die menschen nicht
arbeiten sollen generell finde ich ein
arbeitsverbot für flüchtlinge oder für
menschen dieses land kommt ist völliger
schwachsinn arbeitslose zuwanderer oder
flüchtlinge bringen uns nicht
stattdessen wenn wir die arbeit geben
kann man die sprache besser lernen
später zahlen sie ist zurück durch
sozialleistungen durch steuern und ich
finde dass die ampeln willkommens kurs
ausruft groth ich finde es sogar
grandiose fans treu mich hat das heute
sehr gefreut
ich halte das für eine schlechte idee
wurde mir die menschlichen argumente
total nah sind dass jemand der bei uns
lebt und arbeitet will das auch machen
soll aber man muss bedenken man
vermischt einwanderung und asyl und das
ist ein grundfehler man kann gerne
beides großzügig gestalten aber nicht
vermischen weil dann entsteht genau das
dass die menschen denken du musst nur
irgendwie nach deutschland kommen auf
dem asyl ticket dann musst du irgendwie
da bleiben und dann kommst du da schon
rein und mit dieser einstellung
produzieren wir elend dieses elend kann
man im moment besichtigen an der
polnisch weißrussischen grenze da sind
nämlich leute wo lukas schenkel nur
sagen musst kommt nach deutschland die
wollen die mir leute brechen auf und
laufen in ihr elend und sie laufen auch
in ihr elend in der sahara und sie
laufen ja elend auf den
flüchtlingsbooten auf dem mittelmeer
dieses ganze irreguläre migration ist
elend das ist nicht gut das muss ersetzt
werden durch legale migration aber nicht
vermischt und lass es wirklich verstehe
die beweggründe ich respektiere die aber
ich glaube das ist eine konstruktion
aber wenn die menschen hier sind es habe
ich mich wirklich damals immer gefragt
warum dann nicht das zu erarbeiten was
man machen kann ist was die amerikaner
mal gemacht haben ist eine
stichtagsregelung also man kann sagen
unser asylsystem hat nicht funktioniert
ihr wart hier in zehn jahre duldung das
gibt sogar diese grauenvolle
kettenduldungen ja also haben bei uns in
neukölln kinder der großeltern sich
schon aus dem libanon gekommen da kann
man sagen was macht ein stichtag und
dann organisiert und das system aber
generell zu sagen jeder der bei uns rein
kommt ist irgendwie schafft drei jahre
drin zu bleiben unter welcher methode
auch immer drei jahre nur bei besondere
integrationsleistungen
will ist auch nicht runter also ich
verstehe wirklich den impuls ich will
mich darüber nicht erheben ich verstehe
auch die moral dahinter aber trotzdem es
ist ein eingebauter systemfehler der in
szenen für viele menschen führen kann
aber macht es wirklich jetzt macht
dieses gesetz was dann kommen sollte
macht es wirklich den unterschied ich
glaube nicht also wir nicht mit
flüchtlingen spreche ist deutschland
schon jetzt sozusagen hier gibt es alles
aus deren sicht das wird verbreitet
telegramm bei facebook überall was mich
besonders
bewundert aber auch gesorgt hat an der
polnisch russischen grenze war die
tatsache dass eben ganz viele dort waren
die keine klassischen kriegsflüchtlinge
in dem sinne war sondern aus erbil wo
man sicherlich unter wirtschaftlich
schwierigen bedingungen nur leben kann
aber eben nicht direkt der gefahr
ausgesetzt ist ich habe das gefühl dass
deutschland sozusagen dieses image schon
geprägt hat und
er zum einen bieten nicht gekommen zu
sein hat und nicht nur ihr sehen ich
kann nicht sagen zum beispiel mann ich
habe von dort berichtet lange zeit und
der fahrer mit dem ich immer unterwegs
war lkw fahrer der aus serbien kommt der
dann checke gefahren hat der hat sich
irgendwann gesagt im letzten jahr mensch
hatte das schlimme trennung jetzt
verkaufe ich meinen truck und
irgendjemand hat zu mir gesagt ich kann
mit dem ticket kaufen und dann bin ich
in belarus er hatte keinen kontakt der
südländer sondern etwas gibt es auch
also es gibt beides und ich glaube also
ich wollte nur sagen es ist nicht so nur
weil da jetzt gar keinen krieg ist gibt
es niemanden der verfolgt wird es gibt
zb die siegen aber es gibt natürlich
auch diese fälle die sie jetzt von ihrem
lkw fahrer beschreiben aber die brauchen
wir ja tatsächlich als einwanderer also
ich glaube wenn es so ne sohn alle
kommen aus ihrer sicht nein das hat ja
jetzt frau schön dargestellt und er kann
sich das drama ja gar nicht klar genug
machen also es ist so dass die baby
boomer jetzt alle in rente gehen und
dann ist auch aus wirtschaftlicher und
in deutschland wächst wachsen aber keine
jugendlichen nach genau deswegen gibt es
diese lücke und diese lücke wird immer
weiter wachsen da gibt es auch tolle
statistiken von dem institut für
arbeitsmarkt und berufsforschung und das
ist dann so dass 2050 fehlen im
vergleich zu heute 12 millionen leute
auf dem arbeitsmarkt 12 millionen und
das lustige ist da ist schon
eingerechnet dass er jedes jahr eine
anhörung von tsonga
weil ich glaube das ist ein wichtiger
punkt ich war mal mit angela merkel in
in westafrika und hatte er diese
abkommen gemacht weil da kommen auch
ganz viele leute und hat abend waren die
politiker vor ort teilweise auch dafür
weil das sind ja familien die sammeln
kapital und wir haben dann eben die
entscheidung kaufe ich ein truck mache
ich einen kiosk auf also schaffe ich
etwas mit glück vielleicht so etwas wie
kleine mittelstand wird oder nämlich das
kapital und bezahle die schlepper um
einen durchzubringen nach deutschland
über und es ist für diese gesellschaften
wirklich fatal und selbst wenn ja
demografisches argument stimmen würde
was ich mit verlaub nicht glauben das
stimmen würde wäre es moralisch falsch
zu sagen wir lösen unsere demografische
probleme in dem wir anderen die
aufsteiger und mittelschicht
nur ganz kurz wie es keiner ein wort wie
schaffen wir ist denn sonst den
fachkräftemangel entgegen zu wirken wenn
nicht durch zuwanderung also dass die
das ist wirklich ein signifikantes ich
bin doch nicht durch zufall ich bin
regelt wann kommt klar wir können also
schon eine richtig gute idee ist dass
man fachschulen gründet in diesen
ländern und da werden die leute lernen
ein handwerk und dann kann die deutsche
wirtschaft jedes jahr sagen wir wollen
von denen
2000 und die dürfen dann kommen und die
sind auch sofort arbeiten und die die
nicht dabei sind haben aber was gelernt
und können das zuhause anwenden solche
lösungen kann man für bin ich gegen
zuwanderung aber das schlimme ist doch
diese vermischung strukturell bei uns
ist das drin von asyl und zuwanderung
und die ist nicht gut dabei was
passieren wird und das ist natürlich
dann zynisch aber es wird passieren und
es steht auch im koalitionsvertrag man
wird versuchen die grenzen zu schließen
also da ist auch was also natürlich wie
nebulös wie immer in diesem vertrag der
ist ja relativ niveau liu grenze die ja
da ist was von abkommen werden da
erwähnt und links abgekommen
genau das wird noch nicht mal so konkret
gesagt dass es um flüchtlings abkommen
geht aber zwischen den zeilen ist klar
dass man versucht diese wieder den druck
auf die grenzen zu bremsen und es ist
auch klar gesagt dass rückführung flügel
schneller gehen sollen und dass man das
asylverfahren beschleunigen
es ist ein langes verfahren ist für alle
beteiligten ein unfassbares wenn das
kürzer ist ist das sehr genau und aber
dass ich wollte jetzt nur sagen da gibt
es sozusagen eine klar erkennbare
doppelstrategie die genau in die
richtung von frauchen geht also auf der
einen seite illegale einwanderung auch
als angebot so sagen wir brauchen euch
vielleicht mit diesen fachschulen das
steht dann nicht drin ist aber eine gute
idee und auf der anderen seite
schaltet man aber europa ab also das
kann man jetzt hinten wie man will aber
fakt ist man versucht sozusagen flucht
zu vermeiden dass das steht da glas sein
rennen sollte auch vermieden werden wenn
sie vom info flucht muss das letzte
mittel sein um einem krieg oder einer
diktatur zu ähnlich es fakt wenn der
europa sich abschottet kann man nicht
mehr rein nicht egal wie die umstände zu
hause sind das ist der ist deshalb wurde
kabel wie nimmst du die
migrationspolitik in deutschland war die
durch die ampel neu geprägt werden
könnte also ich habe jetzt die form so
die kommentare gelesen den deutschen
zeitungen auch diesen
entscheidungen diesen
absichtserklärungen und die mayers fazit
ist ein bisschen das ist eine
gefährliche politik die sich meine die
frage wird die zuwanderung dass die
fachkräfte braucht jedes unternehmen hat
den grund einem fachkräftemangel
fachkräfte sind immer mangelhaft weil da
ist eine große nachfrage auf den
arbeitsmärkten das nicht so einfach die
zu finden da müssen die firmen
attraktive rahmenbedingungen bieten die
staaten müssen gute rahmenbedingungen
bieten und das was die ampel macht hier
das wird natürlich nicht das problem
lösen was du dir erträumt das hat man
schon 2015 den leuten erzählt da kommen
alles fachkräften zeit am anfang haben
teilnehmer haben die nicht mehr
arbeitskräfte bekommen ein riesiger
bürokratischer
menschen dürfen nicht arbeiten ja ja
nein wann hat man hat das damals schon
so erklärt das heißt die große der
fachkräfte zuzug der welt weiter sieht
er hat nicht stattgefunden und das
problem ist mit diesen veränderungen das
geht natürlich in die richtung die rubin
alexandria erwähnt hat das ist natürlich
das vermischen von migrations kategorie
und zweitens steckt dahinter natürlich
auch der versuch eine irreguläre oder
eine illegale migration zur legalen zu
machen ganz schön kannst du dass
fachkräfte nicht lösen ja ich habe in
der letzten woche den polnischen
premierminister interview der hat gesagt
er warnt vor 50 millionen migranten die
nach deutschland kommen wollten und wenn
es keine mauer gebe so war seine aussage
und kein permanenten grenzschutz wird
das alles hier in die katastrophe führt
das ist übertrieben die katastrophe ich
bin es nicht apokalyptiker ich bin ich
immer ich bin gar nicht im gegenteil ich
bin ich bin kein untergang spricht ich
habe ich sage dass das migrationsproblem
das ist ein riesiges problem weil der
druck auf europa wird gewaltig sein und
diese druck hat natürlich damit zu tun
wenn leute merken dass hier sich die
stadt dann öffnen wenn man sagt wir
nehmen es nicht mehr so genau mit dem
rechtsstaat mit der zuwanderung wenn man
da ist er kann auch bleiben dann hast du
eine schleppe industrie die weite und
dann das ausnützen und weil die leute
werden kommen ich meine weiterhin die
demografie in afrika anschaut das sind
natürlich gigantische bewegungen und
dann muss ganz klar der rechtsstaat und
wie ich meine bei der migration das
maßhalten muss muss gepflegt werden
zuwanderung ist wichtig dass jedes land
hat eine gewisse zuwanderung aber du
kannst nicht die schweiz hat eine extrem
hohe zuwanderung gehabt in den letzten
15 jahren aber du musst maßhalten und
darfst du musst schauen dass nicht die
falschen leute ins land kommen ich lerne
zuwanderung ist wichtig da sind die
beiden sich einig